excepto la demócrata kamala harris y el
republicano mike pence protagonizará en
un debate presidencial como ningún otro
en la universidad de utah y las
circunstancias no pueden ser más
extraordinarias
el presidente donald trump volvió al
despacho o al tras estar recluido tres
días en el hospital walter reed trump de
74 años tuvo que hacerse a un lado de su
campaña para batallar contra el kobe 19
y no es claro cuándo estará
completamente recuperado por otro lado
si gana joe biden se convertiría en el
presidente más viejo en la historia del
país lo duro que ha golpeado la pandemia
eeuu hace que ahora los reflectores
apunten a harris y fence para ver qué
tan preparados están si el deber los
llama en una esquina separada de su
oponente por divisores de plexiglás está
harris de 55 años la senadora por
california es elocuente y respira
entusiasmo hija de inmigrantes y
abogadas carlo como una estrella en el
partido demócrata por críticas al
entonces candidato de la corte suprema-
brookhaven aps ya la hora fiscal general
william ward el imperturbable mike pence
es de 61 años por otro lado es uno de
los alfiles más leales
este cristiano es gobernador de indiana
es hagas con los medios y ha sabido
sortear cada controversia de la
administración trampa la pandemia
ocupará el primer lugar en la agenda
mientras penn se verá obligado a
defender la gestión del gobierno
harris querrá apuntar a las fortalezas
de wyden en este campo también sobre la
mesa estarán la injusticia racial o la
pelea por el control de la corte suprema